noon everybody this is Laura McDermott
from corn
Extension talking I just want to welcome
you to the northeast ser professional
development project soil management and
berry crops as a model for management
education this is the eleventh in a
series of twelve in depth berry crop
nutrition and soil management trainings
and we're really happy to have you here
as you log on if you would please just
know in the chat box where you are from
and what you work with that would really
help our speaker who is from the
University of Florida get a better idea
of who is in the audience I expect that
we'll have a few more people log on but
in the meantime I'm going to just show
you around in case you have not been
here before I want to make sure that
you're accustomed and familiar with the
Adobe classroom the web links box at the
lower left hand corner is where you can
download you can be linked directly to
the websites that are listed the webinar
archives and northeast sare are listed
there then in the lower right hand
corner are the files that we would be
very happy to have those of you who have
not filled out the educator northeast
educator pretest and the northeast sare
demographics questionnaire both of these
are very important for the grant
information so we encourage you to do
that and send that back to Kathy
Heidenreich but let's just allow just a
few more moments for people to log on
and then I'm going to go into the second
part of the training but just let me
give them another minute or so to make
sure that everybody's logged on I do
want to draw your attention to the fact
that we're looking for a little bit of
input and at the very bottom of the
notes pod if you scroll down Kathy has
stated that there's um if there's any
topics or issues related to bury crop
soil and nutrient management
that have not yet been addressed next
week on March
what is that March 6th excuse me March
9th but if that is the last webinar for
this series that'll be at 2 o'clock p.m.
and dr. Harold Vaness will be leading
that but part of that will be to address
any remaining questions that might exist
so I think at this point let's um let's
move into the second portion of the
webinar and I'd like to introduce to you
our invited speaker dr. Santos not dr.
velinski Santos is an assistant
professor of horticulture with the
University of Florida and IFAs he
conducts research on strawberry tomato
bell pepper and increasingly highbush
blueberry he works out of the sugar I
should have read from the other side I
think it's the research station the Gulf
research station at IFAs and he works
specifically with fertilizer irrigation
protected to agriculture with those
remaining crops and increasingly
blueberries and that's the Gulf Coast
research and Extension Center experiment
center so thank you very much tech chure
dr. Santos sorry I kind of get that
introduction a little bit bobbled but
I'm going to let you take it from here
and people will be continually logging
on I think that dr. Santos had asked him
we spoke about this earlier if you could
hold your questions until the end or if
you want to type them in go ahead but
will we'll take all the questions at the
very end of the presentation so thanks
very much and we'll get started well
thank you Laura I really appreciate the
opportunity to be here today and talk to
a very diverse group of colleagues or
both in research and extension really
appreciate that and also appreciate the
fact that hanging 80 degrees here in
Florida what is kind of coal up there
so if you guys don't fall asleep I'm
gonna try the best to try to keep you
attention towards this next few minutes
as Laura mentioned part of my
responsibilities as the University of
Florida to direct the vegetables more
fruit horticultural program the focuses
on fertilization water management
protected AG and cultural practices for
most of our target crops that include
tomatoes peppers strawberries
blueberries and most carrots
today we are going to be talking mostly
about strawberries and how the
fertigation techniques and some of the
hydroponics and have been experimented
here in Florida and abroad also because
part of the activities that we conduct
both research and extension are not all
in Florida but also in California Spain
Argentina Chile and other parts of the
world where we have all the research
being conducted right now so with with
that said we are going to be focusing
today on three basic aspects and the
fertigation by itself we're going to be
talking about a little bit of the
concepts of this we're gonna be trying
to be really really broad in this
knowing that previous speakers probably
talked a lot of the aspects of the
nutrition and fertilization later we're
going to go to the rate determination
which is sometimes one of the most
important aspects and what relates to
this when it comes to fertigation and
fertilization or strawberries in general
and also the third touch aspect this is
going to be touching on the some of the
diagnostic tools we are using right now
I've been asked to look into not only
the way that we produce strawberries
which is along with California are very
different to the rest of the country we
deal with strawberries as an annual crop
we don't have a second crop or the third
crop like in some cases we have in the
north but also some of the
emergent technologies as some growers
are using not only here bring other
parts of the world when it comes to
fertigation and try to determine the
best way the the best way the crops can
perform so we think it's one of the
subjects you're gonna be seen that we
have certain aspects that we're gonna be
touching
hopefully we're gonna be kind of
thorough about it and give practical
examples of what each one of these
aspects me and what we've been doing in
Florida with regard to each one of them
so when we look at fertigation we we
cannot separate the nutrition aspect
from the irrigation practices and we
always tell everybody that if there is
one thing that we when we talk about
fertilization in general is that there
are not certain recipes that need to be
followed every situation is going to be
different and one thing that you're
gonna see today is that we are not gonna
give specific recommendations blanket
recommendations for everybody to do
fertigation as opposed to touching the
principles that take you to those
recommendations and for you to adjust to
your own programs so well we we call
fertigation on the process by which we
apply fertilizers through the irrigation
system and by doing that we can use two
types of specific specific fertilizers
the ones that are ready to use in a
liquid matrix which is the most common
method that is used by the strawberry
growers here in Florida and in parts of
California and also we have the
hydrosoul soluble salts these are solid
salts just diluted in water they similar
to the ones that you buy sometimes and
they in the hardware stores there you go
by a salt and just dissolve it and apply
it
both of them have pros and cons
obviously when you carrying a big liquid
matrix of fertilizers they charge you a
lot more for the for the cost of taking
the fertilizer to you
because they're carrying a lot of water
with them however these are fashion made
formulas
they are tailored to your specific needs
and you just apply the formula I don't
have to worry about usually about the
formula precipitating to the bottom of
the tank unless it's really cold and you
know exactly what you're applying the
problem with their salts when they had
resolvable in contrast with that is that
usually people the more that you handle
this the more rain is a opportunity for
ever for human error that you're gonna
find because one day somebody is making
the mixes in a week somebody is gonna be
doing it and there might be differences
on the type on the fertilizers you
you've really applying in the field
however we at regardless of the formula
that you use nor fertilization program
is going to be ever efficient if a poor
irrigation program is in place and this
is something that we've been formulating
to our growers this second aspect is
extremely important strawberry growers
and Florida are very efficient handling
the water during the season and that
translates into good use of the
fertilizer this apply during the period
now we know and when we talk to our
growers that usually this process is not
a simple process that that they can do
on their own without the education that
we carry to them and one of the
principles that we tell them all the
time is that nutrients only move as far
as the water moves those nutrients so
they have to be clear about that and
once that's why a lot of strawberry
growers are very very successful in that
regard however many of you might be
wondering you know how they handle
fertilization in a situation like they
do in Florida
well soil this is a type of soil that we
have is very sandy extremely sandy is
the closest that you're gonna find to a
beach without salumi in it and that
makes it
challenging in fact somebody asked me
the other day how we were able to do
this and I just tell them that then we
take a lot of the hydroponic principles
to produce strawberries here because is
the closest to the hydroponic system
that you're gonna find in real life when
you got these deep sands infiltrate
really quickly and that's challenging to
us because when you have a soil like
this when growers apply water and have a
crop like strawberries that we grow in a
annual health system like this when
usually we establish the strawberries
with sprinklers irrigation protect their
berries also with the sprinklers and
have one or two drip tapes like the ones
that you see here at the bottom of this
sliding each one of the beds it creates
an opportunity to apply fertilizers in a
very efficient way but at the same time
it's a challenge it's challenging
because you can have a high risk of
leaching fertilizer and if you don't
believe me that I'm just gonna leave you
with this picture who in this is a
cross-section of a bed sandy bed like we
have here in Florida and the picture on
top represents watering the bed with one
drip tape for one hour that's how
quickly the water moves down without
moving further out on the sides and
that's when we have to challenge
ourselves to keep those nutrients within
that root zone and making sure that
nobody water's excessively so they can
be efficient in when they apply
fertilizers the pictures depict the
second picture at the bottom of the
slide represents beds with to drip tapes
and in both cases this is one hour of
irrigation and the top in that case we
were able to achieve 31% coverage of the
bed of the area of the bed
whereas with to drip tapes you get
barely 67 percent that means two-thirds
of the bed of the are being water
when when you have one-third of the bed
that hasn't been touched by water so you
have to be sure that you know only put
the right rate of fertilizer but also
the placement of the fertilizer along
with the irrigation program has to be
efficient for us to make sure that we
make we make the best use possible of
the resources are put out there in the
field for producing strawberries now
going back a little bit to the
principles that we follow here in
Florida particularly we usually tell our
growers that they shouldn't be
irrigating for more than an hour and the
reason is that those pictures that you
just saw after an hour of irrigation
probably dumping most of your fertilizer
into the aquifers because it just leaks
down also another important thing that
we tell our growers is that they should
have monitoring equipment to make sure
that they monitor how much water they
have in the beds and knowing when to
apply and when to not apply later on
we're gonna see some pictures of the
type of equipment that there be in the
it's being used right now to make sure
that water is used appropriately also we
extensively educate our growers and
knowing the kind of soil that they have
they have to calibrate the soil they
have to know what the field capacity is
because believe it or not all the sands
are not equal there are some sandy areas
here that are very fast very fine sand
that you get a feel capacity when the
soil is burning 12% whereas there are
other areas when you have a heavier type
of sand that Wickfield capacity is
around 18% so they need to know exactly
what kind of soil they have and even
within the same farm no in the pockets
of soils that they might have and I'm
going to provide more lead details later
on on the broad diagnostic of farms in
how growers can section
farm depending on what kind of soil they
have now their whole objective of all
this obviously is to keep the water in
the rooting song and to do that we want
to make sure that our growers at least
have one of these two if not both pieces
of equipment that allow them to monitor
water in the soil
for that we have two basic basic pieces
of equipment ten geometers which are the
traditional piece of equipment that
measures water tension in the soil they
have very decent accuracy even though we
are disputing this more and more because
sometimes in the middle range of
tensions you might not have an accuracy
that that will tell you exactly how much
water you should put out there the
disadvantages that you have to use one
unit per location that you're going to
be collecting data and making sure that
that unit is there and it's clean that
it's not collecting algae and anything
like that extremely easy to use and very
inexpensive however there are the pieces
of equipment like what you see on the
right here the which is called a time
domain perfect reflector reflectometer
which is relatively expensive while
these units can go anywhere from 500 to
thousands of dollars has this handheld
unit that gives you an instant reading
of salt volumetric water and has these
prongs are going to the soil that can be
calibrated at different depths and you
can tell you instantly the the volume of
water that you have in the soil
therefore if you know that your soil
field capacities have 15% at six inches
deep you immediately get a freedom to
tell you that that's what you have over
there and there are another advantage of
this unit that is you can buy one unit
or two units for the whole farm you can
have a farm manager just going around
and just collecting the the volume of
water and soil the beginning of the
cycles or before the beginning of the
irrigation cycles it's very easy to use
however the downside is that could be a
little bit on affordable for some people
there are other units are extremely more
complicated that are based on the same
principle or similar principles but I
think that that escapes the scope of
what we're trying to do today we're not
trying to do a seminar on how to monitor
water but
who use practical tools to monitor water
and in the situation when growers might
be struggling to make a profit so
usually when we go into into also in
farms we try to make growers aware of
the necessity of know what kind of
cultivars they have one thing that we
found is that cultivars might respond
totally different to the same
fertilization in irrigation programs and
obviously varieties that have been bred
in Florida would respond different than
varieties have been bred in California
just basically because they've been bred
into totally different environments so
the selection pressure will be different
and the situation of the California
soils would be different to ours and
that would be true for a lot of
varieties that are bred in all the
regions too so we're trying to develop
tools that allow us to tailor different
formulas for different varieties and
we're gonna talk about that a little bit
later now when it comes to the second
part of the fertigation soil versus
soilless culture I realize that the vast
majority of strawberries in the u.s. are
grown on the soil however there is a a
increase movement of people going in to
protect the culture and going into
soilless culture within those structures
and that requires also for us to provide
knowledge to that increasing group both
were the traditional a market of
strawberries and also the organic market
of strawberries but for that we just
have to make sure that we know the
physical and chemical properties of our
soils if you're doing soils fill
capacity as I mentioned wilting point
texture structure is as important as all
the chemical properties such as organic
matter content pH nutrient content
salinity and kurayan exchange capacity
we have to make sure that our growers
understand that that's extremely
important to adjust those fertilization
programs
when it comes to soilless culture so you
got three different categories of
soilless that you're gonna find you get
the solid substrates
then which we're gonna talk a little bit
in the next slide we got the pure
hydroponics the plans using a liquid
matrix of solution nutritional solution
and also you got it something new that
it's called relatively new that it's
called aeroponics when they plant in the
plant roots and in the air and you get a
constant mist of water with nutrients
and how to spray into it obviously of
all this and the solid substrate is the
most common and the most used normally
here in the US or in other parts of the
world now when talking about soilless
media the basic principle is that we are
just replacing the natural soil with a
lot of these materials however many of
them are naturally deficient on a lot of
nutrients you get you can't you can pick
whatever soilless media is out there and
you're always gonna find efficiencies of
certain nutrients and that's when they
know how comes into play you need to
know what kind of media you have but we
know that a so a good soilless media
should provide good food support good
nutrient water retention allow gas a gas
exchange and also be a pest free
environment because it's a way for us to
get away from the fumigation of the soil
and and and other problems that we may
have now when it comes to mineral origin
media you get paralyzed vermiculite sand
and rock wall which are very common now
there and in the organic side you get
all from very vegetable or animal origin
you got coconut core peat pine bark
compost different types of compost so
kind of compose out there and also rice
hulls that are usually either used as
they are or burnt you look at a lot of
this
cereals and as I mentioned as I put in
in a slide before not necessarily the
cheapest is the best it all depends on
what kind of needs you have what kind of
irrigation fertilization program and
equipment you might have in the farm if
you have an equipment that you can
normally fertilize once per day you
might want to make sure that your soil
is media adjust to that type of regime
otherwise you're gonna may be running in
trouble here in Florida we have some
specific examples of soils and
containers that are being used for
strawberry production this is a grower
field here in Florida when we get
strawberries growing troughs and those
troughs are filled with pine bark all of
this with drip tape and fertigation also
bags almost very close to the soil or
over these concrete blocks when when we
fill the bags with pine bark also you
got all the growers that have bags that
are filled with coconut coir usually
these bags are pre-mixed and bring the
coconut coir and usually it's imported
from Asia and finally you have also
growers that much being have been
struggling in the past and have tables
like this and they may be reusing those
tables for something else like people
that have nurseries before and we've
been converting some of these people to
producing strawberries on top of the
tables with substrate also other people
have been looking into vertical
production with these vertical systems
they they they might save a lot of space
however usually when you've run into
these lower levels then the light
quality and intensity is a problem and
strawberries minor flower to well down
there however in the first two three
four five levels depending on where you
are and the type of plastic cover that
you have on top you might be very
successful producing the crop now moving
on
when we look at the injection equipment
for fertilizers you usually are talking
about two or three classical pieces of
equipment that are convenient and some
of them are very cheap it has pros and
cons with regard to one and two went to
the other
the first piece of equipment that I want
to show you is what they call the
venturi sock suction injector this is a
very simple system however the problem
is that when you have a system like this
you ask the pressure of the line of the
water line changes you might be changing
the pressure and the injection of this
each one of these Venturi's into the
line which is going to end giving you a
very valuable fertilizer rate that
you're going to be applying so this is
very simple method very inexpensive for
a lot of growers but they required to
monitor the injection of each fertilizer
more efficiently that they would do with
a system like this this is a what
usually they very constant injection
they could be both hydraulic like the
one on the left or they could be
electric like the one on the right and
there is a company that is called
dosatron that's why we're taking the
name from no endorsement intended here
but these systems inject a very constant
rate at the very broad range of pressure
water pressure so if you go from 20 psi
to 10 psi you're gonna continue
injecting this in a concentration of
fertilizer into the stream which is
going to allow you to have the same rate
it's just at the irrigation and the
fertigation process is going to last
longer if the pressure drops so for
those of you who may have plenty of
money to go into it especially growers
there are some computerized consoles
that do all this for you and you you
don't have to mess around a lot with
this system because they adjust the
fertilization throughout the season by
themselves you just have a program that
goes into but this these are a lot more
expensive than all those methods and one
thing that we want to make sure is and
take-home message is that more expensive
known as
certainly means better the e depends
also how you set up your system and how
committed you are to be precise in terms
of a fertilization that you're gonna be
applying in many cases when you got
hydro soluble fertilizers you get a
multi tank injection point when you get
one tank for every type of fertilizer
you're gonna be applying out there for
example in this tank in the left in this
case you've got the assets like
phosphoric acid is being injected
through that tank and this one you got
micronutrients that are being injected
in all the cases you've got phosphates
and sulfates and in the other one you
have nitrates the idea for this is you
don't mix a lot of this fertilizers
because they can precipitate to the
bottom so they if you have a hydro
soluble fertilizer you need to separate
them and make sure that you inject the
right proportion of all of them this is
a very common system that is used in
greenhouses all over the world
when salts are added to water instead of
ready to use liquid solutions like we
use in the open field in Florida in many
parts of California so moving on to rate
determination which is the second part
of our our conversation today you're
gonna see a lot of now practical
examples on how we calculate rates for a
strawberry production in Florida I just
want to put this slide here so you every
fresh into you what the macro
micronutrients are and a lot of these
formulas sometimes might not have all
the micronutrients and they need to be
supplemented depending on the soil needs
that you have so but even more important
that even as important as rate
determination also we need to make sure
that we know the sources a place the
placement of the fertilizer and the
timing when all this is going to be done
and to make sure that we sometimes in
some cases for some micronutrients like
for example zinc or iron or software we
use blanket recommendations because
sometimes we don't have space
calibrated test that will tell you
exactly how much we need an assist in
that place or you might have a piece of
land that is brand-new that nobody has
done any test and any strawberries in
that part of the state and you may need
to do use blanket recommendations while
you calibrate the system in any ways
when you are determining the the
specific rate of application you have to
make sure that you take into account the
crop requirement the leeching the losses
through volatilization and chemical and
biological immobilization in the soil
and that's going to give you a rough
application rate that you're going to be
applying all these pools we take it into
account when determining the best rate
for producing for applying and
fertilizing and producing strawberries
in our state now at the same time we say
that we mentioned earlier that the
different cultivars with different
growing rates on plant architecture is
going to play major role in how much
fertilizer you put out there so we focus
a lot of our attention here in Florida
to looking at pre-planning early in and
pea fertilization as well as at the
adjustments during the season of
nitrogen and potassium throughout the
production cycle to give you a clearer
picture of what we do in that regard we
concentrate a lot on nitrogen and
potassium because these two are the most
used nutrients or the most of applied
nutrients in our situation nitrogen is
you should apply hundred-percent through
the drip tapes sometimes some people may
apply a little bit in pre plant six
years ago this was around 60% of the
acreage right now we are only below 20%
of the acreage of people that apply
pre-plan nitrogen supplement that with
trip later on they usually the rates
were between 20 and 50 pounds per acre
of nitrogen that were applied before the
drip tapes were in in the case of
potassium 100 percent is delivered
through the drip tapes a lot of this as
we
changing in the recent years because of
the environmental concerns that we have
in terms of nitrate moving into the
ground waters and also implementing best
management practices for the crop
however there is no a single best
management practice better than rising
prices of fertilizer and sometimes I say
that in a way that sounds sarcastic but
that has created a more conscience
throughout growers of how to use
fertilizer more efficiently because the
prices have been going up in the year
2000 one ton of fertilizer was below
$200 an acre
there $200 a ton and right now the
fertilizers are above 500 and that has
created a conscience of we need to be
more efficient applying fertilizer for a
strawberry fertilization a common very
common fertilization program here in
Florida is using one to one and a half
pounds of nitrogen per acre per day
which is going to add up to around 150
to 175 pounds per acre per season
remember our season starts in October
and we are done at the beginning of
March it's a very short season because
our market is the winter market and
after that other states take over the
production in the state and we become
really hot to produce strawberries so in
that short season we apply usually
between 150 hundred seventy-five pounds
per acre potassium is a little higher
because people have the perception that
apply more potassium at the end is going
to increase fruit quality which we're
gonna try to illustrate you on that
regard in the next slides and also we
are more conscious right now about
looking up phosphorus in the early
stages of production now when it comes
to using starter fertilizer for applying
nitrogen we've conducted research in the
past where we compared them no
application of pre-planned fertilizer
versus the application of 50 pounds per
acre of pre-plan night
using ammonium nitrate as the source and
what we found in that research
consistently over time is that there was
no significant difference across the
board in any of the months when we
compared the production of strawberries
by not using starter fertilizer or using
starter fertilizer at the beginning and
this was done over a period of three
years and this this is important because
it means not only that the growers might
be saving around 17 to 20 bucks an acre
on the application plus the labor and
everything else but also is 50 pounds
per acre and you multiply that by 10,000
acres that's a tremendous amount of
fertilizer I was just sitting there and
doing absolutely nothing for the crop so
after that you know a lot of growers
were moving out of the business of
applying pre-plan nitrogen to the crop
and what they did is that they started
applying a connecting the drip tape as
early as possible to the crop and
started injecting nitrogen fertilizer as
soon as the plan was on the ground and
they did that for the first 10 days well
we also conducted research looking at
this but this time we made it a little
bit more complicated and we took two
different varieties to varieties are
standards for us spur Florida Strawberry
Festival which is the most grown variety
here in Florida and that is the red line
and Florida radiance that is the blue
line and we found is that these two
varieties I had two totally different
architectures react totally different to
that initial fertilizer rate that you're
putting out there in this case we
compare zero 0.51 and one and a half
pounds per acre per day in those two
varieties for the first 10 days after
transplant we injected that amount and
we collected the early years of the
varieties and what we found is obviously
with zero there was no difference but
we're two totally different patterns as
you increase it to 0.5
per acre you can see here that so very
first about continues increasing its
early yield as you move to one pound and
stabilizes after that
whereas with for the radians the maximum
yield was obtained with 0.5 pounds
those are applied more than that there
were no significant differences from
that obtaining at 0.5 pounds per acre
that is giving us more confirmation that
we need to design more tailor-made
formulas for specific cultivars and
taking into account that many growers
apply as much as one and one and a half
pounds per acre across the board for all
the varieties now we have to come up
with ways to differentiate across the
cultivars and part of the research that
we conducted had a lot to do with that
and that's what you see in right there
we look at two other two varieties and
then we start applying nitrogen
throughout the season which is different
what you just saw what you just saw
previously was nitrogen at the beginning
starting in the season and we started
looking at nitrogen throughout the
season now in two different varieties
and I have to make a a note here that
this is regardless of the source we
didn't find any significant differences
if we were using calcium nitrate and all
the nitrogen sources we were getting
similar responses as you're going to see
in a second what we found again is that
there are different responses across
cultivars regardless of the source of
the fertilizer that you're using and so
varieties like this blue line winner
dawn which is a very small plant all it
requires is three quarters of a pound of
nitrogen per acre per day whereas a big
variety like Strawberry Festival needs
to get at least to 1.25 pounds per acre
per day to maximize early yields well
when we look at that we say okay what
about if we start comparing this to a
new variety like Florida radiance
and we did a similar study when we were
looking at that and we found that again
we had two very similar of two very
different patterns in the two varieties
radiance and festival when radiance was
maximizing at 0.75 three-quarters of a
pound and festival was getting the
maximum at 125 so that's giving us extra
confirmation where it's even more
important that extra half pound per acre
per day if you were applying in radiance
without needing it it might mean 60
pounds per acre per season that's a
tremendous investment that you don't
need when you're producing Florida
radiance so what about nitrogen and
potassium ratios during the season we've
been told and led to believe them by
switching potassium towards the end in
strawberries it's a good thing to
increase increased fruit quality well
we've been doing studies when we are
looking at the traditional grower
practice that is applying a formula like
6 0 4 7 0 4 during the season until
mid-december and switching later to a
heavy potassium formula like four zero
six or four zero eight towards the end
supposedly to improve quality well
research has been conducted in that
regard and what we found out
consistently is a plant diameter when
you go in different ratios one to one
one to twenty one to 125 and one to one
and a half nitrogen to potassium there
were no significant differences across
the board
you
you
however when we move to total fruit
weight of the plants that was the same
pattern that was occurring with plant
diameter when there were no differences
among all the ratios that were use the
same occurred when we look into the
soluble solid content or the breaks of
the fruit there were no differences of
the ratios remember that when I'm
talking the ratios here growers tend to
switch to one to one-and-a-half pounds
during the seat during the end of the
season to increase quality
well that wasn't needed of in any of the
three varieties that we tested
consistently in the last two years here
so there goes the myth that potassium
heavier they at the end increases the
quality and the thought of fruit number
and weight what the we did fine and this
was spected where differences across the
cultivars and I was suspected so when it
comes to changing nitrogen and potassium
during the season we can conclude that
that we can use a saying fertilizer rate
to throughout the season provided that
you provided the correct rate from the
beginning and the plan has developed a
very good ruling system to go down there
and get the fertilizer that you already
been applying in the beds and you
keeping all those nutrients without the
root zone now also we are looking into
making sure that we adjust the practices
for specific growers and that growers
design programs that make sense for the
needs now how do we design these
programs in the sensing how we monitor
all this throughout the season obviously
the diagnosis diagnostic tools are going
to be a tremendous help for us and yeah
I know a lot of the visual assessment is
dawn during the season ain't nothing
beats you all nice but the problem is
that usually when you see it efficiency
is kind of late is usually it has taking
a toll on the crop and you see a
situation like like in this picture on
the right you got a severe deficiency
here and and you want to make sure that
you get to the plant before the leaves
turn this yellow obviously strong
efficiencies cannot be seen a plain
sight and we need to monitor nutrients
throughout the season we usually tell
our growers that there are several tools
out there now they need to make sure
that they have and no specific tool is
it's going to help you to do a one fits
all type of diagnostic sometimes you
need you need you want all eyes out
there looking at the field also you need
also to do probably some kind of
colorimetric test at the same time you
might do the foliar test of to the
plants in the past
aperio sap has been used there are
several there are severe contradictions
out there on where this is the right
time to use a pareo SAP test and whether
this is a really valuable tool to
measure deficiencies in plant because
some people argue that when you have
high concentrations in the patio barrios
act as reservoirs for nutrients and not
necessarily means what is going through
the vascular tissue to the leaves so
that that's one thing that keep an eye
on and not only to use pareo samples and
only test all the people or also look at
colorimetric measurements to determine
the greenness of the leaves especially
if looking for nitrogen magnesium iron
deficiencies and they use this pad meter
which measures the greenness of the
leaves and those are just two of the
most common tools that I use out there
however when you look at the composition
of nutritional composition of the leaves
are usually nothing beats a good leaf
analysis the downside of this is that
obviously by the time you collect the
samples and send it to the lab you get a
results back several days might go by
and that's why the Monday the proactive
approach of making sure that your
solutions are accurate that you have the
right pH that you have the right
electric electrical conductivity of the
solution which by the way we haven't
touched a lot but usually you get
certain targets like for the pH of the
solution you don't want to go above
seven point six or or even to eight nor
lower than six point two to make sure
that you have the right solution out
there it's also gonna depend on what
kind of media you have if you're growing
in the soil or if you're go in the media
that captures or retains a lot of those
nutrients that might give you more
leeway in terms of what kind of solution
you might want to apply out there at the
same time the electrical conductivity of
the solution you don't want it to be too
high I know that's particularly a pro a
problem in places when you have very
high EC of the water for example here in
Florida in our station our water is
seven point seven zero point seven deci
Siemens per meter the electrical
conductivity of our solution so when we
apply fertilizer we usually don't want
to go above two because strawberries are
extremely sensitive to any solution that
is applied to them consistently above to
the Zee Siemens per meter so you want to
make sure that you keep the balance and
that's going to have a direct influence
and what frequency of fertilization
you're gonna use if for is to obtain
they give a fertilizer rate that you
want is gonna take that solution above
two then you probably better off
lowering the concentration of your
solution and applying the aplanet more
frequently so all those are aspects that
we work with growers to make sure that
they have the right program in place so
they don't know
and start seeing salinity problems and
pH the pH disorders and the soil they're
gonna gonna start showing in the plant
some of these problems and also blocking
the absorption of certain nutrients
nevertheless we have a sufficiency range
for strawberries that our university has
put together in our production handbook
and we get certain guidelines not no
rating strong but certain guidelines and
how much nitrogen phosphorus potassium
calcium magnesium sulfur iron manganese
zinc boron copper and molybdenum the
plant needs in a driveway basis when
when it comes to adequate range of
fertilization all this is available
either through our website here my
program or the Extension website of the
university that is free of charge
it could be accessed from anywhere if
anybody has a question about later on
and would like that table to head to you
you can either get a copy of the
presentation or to access the website
and I will be happy to direct you to the
right tri spot below that table we have
another table as I mentioned earlier we
used all these measurements all these
diagnostic tools to complement each
other you get a table
now also show show you the perceived
sufficiency ranges for our conditions
for nitrate nitrogen in the periods and
also for potassium in the in the leaves
so all that is available at the same
time and both tables are together like
that so we just want to make sure that
we design the right problems for our
growers now towards the end and we are
in the last few slides here we want to
concentrate all also in what it's out
there now I know a lot of people use
area photographs as a tool to diagnose
symptoms and this is extensively using
agronomic
props when people corn soybeans and
other crops out there and it's a tool
that is being used more increasingly
more in vegetables now especially when
this extent groaning extended areas
people are using strong and more
actively need nitrification inhibitors
just to read slow down the process of
conversion from from nh4 to nitrate and
also more and more people are using club
crop reflectance measurements that are
is just a sophisticated method to
determine the colors of the planning on
what is reflecting from the plans and I
know some fellow scientists have been
working actively in this and I wouldn't
be surprised in the next few years
this method takes it's used a lot more
extensively in the u.s. one of the
methods is being used here in Florida
especially for people have large very
large strawberry areas talking above 100
acres he's using the aerial infrared
photographs as you can see in this
picture it gives you a good idea of what
the high vigor areas and you feel are
and what the low areas are and usually
that's tied up to the the specific
properties of the soil or specific
practices of that soil for example in
that specific case you're gonna you're
gonna see the areas in green that
represent the low vigor areas of that
field and reading a little bit of the
narrative for this picture those were
areas that were both either poor
fumigated or have very limiting drainage
situations in it and this is a tool that
is being used more actively now to know
what you have in the field make sure
that you make adjustments either on that
season or for next season to do
amendments pinpointed to
cific blocks of land of you feel as you
can see here you get in the left side of
this picture you get nine different
fields all of them with very different
vigor with the same variety and that
allows that grower to to say okay this
is a very low spot this is a very high
spot or this is a spot that has high
organic matter than the other and that
allows you to make adjustments now
towards the end now we are looking more
increasingly into looking at the effect
of nutrients and growth and quality not
only the traditional nitrogen and
potassium but also I mentioned that
we've been focusing even more important
phosphorus now the reason is because
even our soils have a lot of phosphorous
available sometimes we see phosphorus
addition increasing the quality of the
of the plant and then that's probably
because when the young transplant is
putting in the beds you don't have
enough phosphorous around that root zone
for the new roots to absorb it at the
given time so you might have phosphorus
and environment but might not have
everywhere you want it so we we are
working on that too the other thing that
we're doing is working actively on
management of soilless culture to make
sure that growers have what they need
and it's every specific soilless medium
has specific characteristics and we want
to make sure that we pinpoint to them
what are the practices that they need
for specific conditions that they might
have in the farm if you get any further
questions are beyond this seminar I'm
putting my email there so anybody can
feel free to expand over this and
discuss this a little bit further or if
any other subject was left out we'll be
more than happy to answer your question
just allow me couple days for it because
I keep traveling all over the world so
sometimes I might not even be in the
country when I might be
answering some of the questions but I
will be happy to do it because this kind
of exchange with people from other
states from colleagues researchers and
extension is is what really was and
reaches the process of gaining knowledge
and generating technologies for our
growers and all the growers in the US
with that I'm gonna leave it for
questions and I appreciate your
attention today and your patience with
all this presentation dr. Santos thank
you so much this is Laura speaking and
we do have a couple of questions that
people have typed in I imagine there's a
few other questions out there so those
of you in the audience go ahead and if
you have them please type them in I have
a few but first Jeff Miller asks whether
or not you've compared the use of
calcium nitrate with urea or ammonium
sources of nitrogen for trickle
solutions well that's a great question
as I mentioned before we've compared
those sources and talking about culture
nitrate and ammonia sources and we have
found no significant differences in the
way that it's used for strawberries now
if we were talking about other crops he
might make a whole lot of a difference
especially blueberries that we know that
respond a lot better to you know three
sources than rather than ammoniacal
sources but in the case of our
strawberries and the way that growers
handle it and the rates that we use we
haven't found any significant
differences across the board all right
thank you and the beginning portion of
you started talking about ratios of n to
K where K was less than a one-to-one
ratio you were talking I think more
about caving a higher ratio but can you
mention if you checked those ratios
where K was actually less yes we have
met we have checked those ratios before
and we decided to leave that out of the
research because in preliminary studies
found out that those ratios that
correspond to less than one pound per
acre per day of potassium really start
taking a toll on the plants
so usually from the condition that the
growers have here in California growers
tend to over apply fertilizer not to
under apply and but by looking at those
ratios a preliminary stuff a research
that we conducted told us that yes we
didn't need to go lower than that but
rather to compare one one and a quarter
and one and a half pounds of potassium
during the season which is the most
common practice for those growers here
okay and then we have one more question
and I think you mentioned that the goal
for the pH of your solution would be a
six point two of a low and then the
maximum would be seven point six and
eight point zero that's correct
and those are the extremes and you tried
to have a a nutritional solution that
doesn't go below six point five and
that's it go say hi at a seven point
three or something like that if you have
to do for a short time with a solution
that is seven six seven eight it's not
the end of the world but that tends to
accumulate over time so for a given
point in time when you're applying that
you might might be fine especially if
the plans are big and vigorous they can
take it really well however you try to
stay close to neutrality as much as
possible okay wonderful we have another
question